so und jetzt sitzen wir hier wieder am
kamin das feuer brutzelt und es ist
natürlich kein echtes aber bitte wir
müssen mit dir natürlich sprechen
alexander heute du hast adels insider
teile seiner familie das jetzt schon was
du mich fragen wie teile deiner familie
sind ja verwandt sogar mit den windsors
wie wir gestern bei dir gelernt haben
deine kinder sind am platz
847 in der thronfolge hast du das
nachgeschaut nein ich möchte sagen
zwischen den 600 dann würde ich seit
zwei jahren 600 und 700 macht sie nicht
niedriger als die schwere werdet noch
etwas geduld haben aber es bringt ja
auch nicht immer glück wie wir gerade
wieder sehen gestern abend lief eine
neue bbc-dokumentation da ging es wieder
einmal um den bruderkrieg william und
harry und diesmal war es zu sagen der
vorwurf dass william die presse oder
zumindest aus dem königshaus heraus
schmutzige details an die presse
weitergegeben wurden insbesondere auch
über das verhältnis von harry und megan
ist das vorstellbar dass tatsächlich
solche insider informationen direkt aus
dem königshaus an die presse weiter
durch gestochen werden also nochmal der
vorwurf ist konkret an william und an
williams team das er die presse brief
tat gegen medien also zum beispiel gab
es ja gab es ja diese zeitungsberichte
dass sie sehr grob mit dem personal um
ging und dass sie sehr herrisch war und
sehr kapriziös und da muss ich ehrlich
sagen da braucht braucht es nicht um
william um die presse dafür um das in
die presse durch zu stecken das war so
bekannt im buckingham palast und london
ist wirklich ein sieb was diese
informationen anbelangt also das kam
auch ohne william an die presse aber
selbstverständlich ist es denkbar dass
leute aus dem umfeld das ist ja auch
immer ein sehr weit zu denen der begriff
die presse informiert haben und sicher
sicher auf beiden seiten und das
interessante ist auch wirklich dass das
ein auf ein krieg hinausläuft zwischen
der bbc und dem königshaus also das gab
es eigentlich nicht babyzimmer immer
königs und staatstreue und naja dann
kamen das interview mit lady da
näher als der große der erste große
bruch also der bruder von daher bbc
verklagt hat weil sie eben dieses
interview sich auf kriminelle weise
erschlichen haben und jetzt diese
wirkliche die hat provokation dem
königshaus gegenüber die habe mir diese
doku gemacht hat das königshaus gesagt
können wir das bitte sehen um uns auch
dazu äußern zu können babys hinein also
ich bin sehr gespannt mit welchen
sanktionsmaßnahmen die npd die familie
reagieren würde ich bin sicher dass die
bbc auf jahrzehnte hinaus
keine sonderbehandlung mehr wie in der
vergangenheit immer üblich war ja auch
eine scharfe reaktion also schafe royale
verhältnisse wo es normalerweise heißt
never experten aber komplett also weder
erklären noch beschweren wir sagen gar
nichts sie sind dass diese ordnung ist
so ein bisschen die strafe städten und
so es gibt übrigens auch aus dem
bedeutenden nicht immer nur nach england
schauen es gibt ja auch rolls in
deutschland und auch da gibt es
interessante nachrichten ernst-august
hannover hat ja seinen sohn verklagt
wegen groben undank wollte
stücke zurück haben darunter ein ganzes
schloss marienburg marienburg und der
prozess ist geplatzt oder es geplatzt
weil der anwalt von ernst august
hingeschmissen hat also ich kann mir
vorstellen als 1 august office line
overmann das ist schwierig ich würde
sagen
kein ganz einfacher mandant ist ja die
marienburg ja die steht in niedersachsen
ist ein niedersachsen glaube ich für von
seinem sohn für einen euro oder sowas
verkauft worden soll also ebenso zusagen
für die öffentlichkeit daran und da war
ernst august der vater nicht
einverstanden also die genauen details
tätigkeiten gehen ich nicht aber so gut
so viel ich weiß ist auch ein teil in
den stiftungen eingegangen und der sohn
von ernst august hat im grunde dass die
vermögensverwaltung des der
hannoverschen besitze
besitzt sie hat aber dann sein vater
nicht ganz korrekt behandelt in ihnen
wohl und der hat sich dann gewehrt und
wollte hat ein anwalt wieso nicht ganz
billig sein
schloss hinzu
großes thema wir haben schon breaking
news sendungen dazu gehabt die ampel
koalitionsverhandlungen stehen
unmittelbar vor neben ende heute nacht
könnte womöglich schon die tinte unter
das papier gesetzt werden
wie geht's dir damit hast du da eine
vorfreude da beginnt jetzt was neues
hast du deine eine positive erwartung
also gut dass du mich zu einem thema
befragt du nämlich keine ahnung habe
ich freue mich auf die regierung habe
aber jetzt keine besonderen erwartungen
ich würde mir ein außenminister maß
weiter wünschen so viel ich höre mit
augenmaß zehn posten verlieren das finde
ich schade wie denkst du denkst du für
mich ist es erst mal so ich finde es
ganz ganz traurig wenn etwas neues
beginnt nach 16 jahren und man gleich
schon wieder als berufs skeptiker die
wir journalisten ja sind gleich schon
wieder sozusagen nach all den fehlern
die da alle wieder passieren werden
logischerweise auch sucht so ich hab
schon eigentlich so ein gefühl auch gut
dass mal etwas neues beginnt und gibt
denn auch mal eine chance und ich glaube
das ist ja auch bei uns fast üblich also
aus aber der bezahlung aber eben
immerhin allgemein gibt man so einen
neuen papst ohne neue regierung 100 tage
wo sie sich erstmal zu recht stramm
bringen können und dann fangen wir an
auf die finger zu apropos papst joachim
sauer der ehemann der noch kanzlerin
angela merkel hat jetzt der
italienischen zeitung la repubblica ein
interview gegeben und da wurde er
gefragt warum wenn in deutschland ein
drittel immer noch nicht geimpft sein
und da hat er gesagt wahrscheinlich
liege es an der faulheit und
bequemlichkeit der deutschen ein
seltsamer satz oder also ich glaube dass
einer was man mit uns deutschen nicht
assoziiert ist faulheit und
bequemlichkeit also ich habe mich über
diesen satz eher gewundert ich hab mich
auch gewundert dass überhaupt teil der
re publica ein interview gegeben hat
aber der anlass ist wohl dass er ihr
berufen worden ist in die akademie der
wissenschaften von turin und wir haben
ihn dann dazu gefragt warum die
impfquoten in deutschland zu niedrig
sind abgesehen von dem satz über die
bequemlichkeit habe ich mir bei den
anderen satz
rausgesucht ich interessant finde was
sag ich muss sie vorlesen weil ich habe
es nicht denn ich weiß es nicht
auswendig eine weitere gruppe sagt er
sind menschen die einer persönlichen
überzeugung folgen einer art
ideologischer
eine art ideologische reaktion auf das
was sie für eine impf diktatur halten
darunter und das finde ich interessant
dass er das sagt darunter sind auch
akademiker ärzte und wissenschaftler zu
finden und da muss ich sagen das finde
ich ihnen gerne eine interessante
analyse denn ich sträube mich so ein
bisschen dagegen alle leute diese wie
die impf skeptiker sind über den kamm zu
scheren und als alu hütte zu bezeichnen
und als verschwörungstheoretiker da sind
tatsächlich wie baby professor sauer
sagt eben auch akademiker
wissenschaftler und ärzte dar und
deutlich finden kann man durchaus ernst
nehmen und das kann ich irgendwie
wichtigen satz wie stellst du dir wenn
du es dir auswahl würde es wie stellst
du dir das vor wenn jetzt angela merkel
rentnerin ist also die rentner sind
angela merkel lebt mit dem professor
joachim sauer zusammen wie könnte der
alltag bei denen aussehen was machst du
da so ein bisschen wie bei pappa ante
portas nur andersrum mama ante portas
ich glaube der wissenschaftler sauer hat
auch ganz gern so sein sein sein reich
für sich ich bin mal gespannt wie er mit
dieser powerfrau training voraus
zurechtkommt ich glaube sie werden sich
sehr viel in konzerte und opern flüchten
die lieben klassische musik ich glaube
sie werden sehr viel in konzertsälen
verbringen da hast du schon wieder ein
stichwort gegeben musik volker
lechtenbrink ein großer deutscher mit 77
jahren nach schwerer krankheit gestorben
was verbindest du mit dem ich fast
traurig als sie die nachricht hörte und
haptik bild zeitung von morgen
durchgeschaut und da ist ein wirklich
wirklich wirklich sehr sehr schöner nach
auf ihn von einer kollegin die ihn seit
jahren begleitet hat und in diesen
wenigen zeilen ist dieser mensch sehr
schön zusammengefasst und ich habe
einmal nur in einer ein erlebnis mit ihm
gehabt ich habe ihm ich habe aber auf
einer
schifffahrt kennengelernt habe der guten
ms deutschland und habe dort mehrere
sehr schöner abend mit ihm verbracht die
zum teil auch etwas feucht waren also er
hat er hat auch gern mal zum glas
geklärt sein das traumschiff genau das
was das traumschiff er war er war
eingeladen als als gast um dann säle zu
füllen auch ich war eingeladen als gast
bei ihm war immer der saal der ballsaal
proppevoll bei mir waren so drei alte
rentnerin die gekommen sind um zu hören
was ich aus meinen büchern vorzulesen
habe aber er war ein absoluter
publikumsmagnet diese tolle stimme ganz
viele dokumentationen auch als sänger
auch im kopf ein ganz großer
schauspieler also seine erste berühmte
rolle war ja in der verfilmung von
diesen berühmten roman von bernhard
wicki die brücke waren jungen 14 jahre
war zehn jahren in alten er spielt einen
jungen der vorkommen hoffnungslosen
kampf geschickt wird von den nazis also
am ende des krieges sind sieben jungen
in den kampf geschickt worden um eine
brücke sinnlose also verteilt hat
tolle rollen von ihm und vor allem an
den ich mich in diesen abend zurück
denke an einen sehr ernsthaften
melancholischen
großartigen eine großartige
persönlichkeit und ich muss sagen ich
habe aus dem text der der bild morgen im
nämlich dass er nicht an corinna
gestorben ist sondern krebs hatte und
das ist ja sehr sehr traurig sp zu jung
gestorben 77 77 stoßen wir noch einmal
auf ihn an vielen dank für das gespräch
alexander ich muss gleich wieder hoch
ins studio du hast nur zu